you can't block something
that doesn't
lock
so what am I doing I'm you I'm going
down another Street
in other words I'm working from this bit
down because this bit up is completely
blocked
I mean my modern sat now says
cues ahead
we have another route I'm gonna ignore
it that'll be fine
yeah so so when you're being blocked by
a powerful person
yeah
I mean
so coke you is actually understanding
it's not giving you more power
yes there is power if I want to unleash
the power I can unleash it
but I'm doing enough to make him fall
over so and that's all any of you will
want is it to get rid of them and to
look good at the end of it
so you're being blocked
so that's all I can tell you
but until you actually decide the sat
nav knows better what they don't
normally does it so that's a that's a
bad coincidence but General I mean
you've got to explore other places
because if you're blocked
if I was to do code and he blocks me
done my heart I
I'm here
so as you start to understand I'm now
going to do that but I'm actually going
to go here down not here up
so this is again Mass
so you're not going to understand
everything that I teach today of course
you're not but we'll try this again
and if a person blocks you
just trying to go through it thinking
that you've got the wrong technique
you're you're wrong you're you're
thinking wrong you've got to go where
you can go not where you come
the problem is you're trying to keep to
this sort of formula aren't you of
everything looking like this but this is
actually
all down here you're you're shifting
your way you turn your hips the last
thing to actually move is the upper body
and the arms that's the last thing what
you're doing is you're going oh he's
blocked me
so you're not even getting to shifting
your weight turning your hips
to see if that'll work you're not even
getting that far to see if that bit will
work